for the fifth time we present to you the
human era calendar for the year 12021
this time it's all about the journey of
humanity
beginning tens of thousands of years ago
leading into the revolution of
agriculture to ancient high
civilizations
and the beginning of modern times
culminating in a vision for our future
you can get the limited edition now
until we set out and then
never again as always the calendar
features 12 illustrated pages printed on
high quality paper in europe and the us
and this year the cover is especially
shiny
not only does the calendar look great on
walls and makes it easier to dream about
a glorious future
and realize how far we've come as a
species it's also the best way to
support kotzkazak
the calendar enables us to put in the
time our videos need and release them
for free for everyone
if you want you can get the calendar
with a hoodie or infographic posters or
plushie we've made a few deals for you
thank you so much to the thousands of
people who get the calendar every year
and to the burbs who love what we try to
do on this channel
we wish you a happy year 12021 and let's
all hope that it will be less exciting
than 12020